foreign
you're listening to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we're the
minimalists and of course we're here
with our good friend TK Coleman sending
love and holiday cheer to all which
holiday hey man every day flag day every
day is a holiday man oh my goodness you
just gotta bring it and that disembodied
voice you hear is our favorite
disembodied voice
malabama's here hi everybody we got the
rest of our team here in the studio as
well and we're gonna do our best not to
tear up during this episode because we
have a big announcement but as you know
this is a listener driven show so if you
have a question for the show give us a
call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast that the minimalists.com we'll
answer your question on a future show or
you can send in your comments your
minimalist tips as well today we're
starting with a question from patreon
Kaylee has a question for us in your
recent false self episode The
camaraderie between Joshua and Ryan is
profoundly uplifting and appreciated I
truly love watching your friendship
evolve how has it evolved over the past
years 32 years and how do you think it
will evolve going forward 32 years
indeed Nicodemus yeah man you're getting
old yeah I know it's your fault
if we were friends I wouldn't be getting
this old
actually I would say you actually keep
me younger it's been really good man wow
wow I don't know what my rigidity is
like it gives you bounds uh no you got
good energy and um dude in a way you're
you've played my conscience a lot in my
life you have
um been my mentor and yeah man like no
the 32 years like I don't
I don't uh
don't forget a day of it okay I forget a
few days but there's a lot I don't
forget yeah especially like uh like
2004. I couldn't tell you what the heck
happened in 2004. in fact we have a
photo tour we're gonna go through today
of the minimalists over the years from
1981 until today in fact we have we have
one photo from the future
oh wow we're gonna go through that as
well but we have a big announcement I
want to start there and we're going to
address Kaylee's question head on
um big announcement I got a new shirt
I thought I'd noticed something
different about you
what you really need is a pack of
cigarettes though to roll up in those
sleeves
that would be cool if you're listening I
want the cigarette in his ears
right uh if you listen to the just the
audio version of the podcast for today's
400th episode that's right this is
episode number 400 I'm wearing a special
shirt it's just a purple shirt yes we're
talking about clothes later in this
episode as well but no the big
announcement is after six years here in
Los Angeles Ryan is uh making his way
back to Montana after this episode yeah
man me and Mariah are going back I was
gonna say going home but
was it just in Ireland for three weeks I
kind of felt like home La kind of feels
like home yeah no I'm gonna use the
doctor Bush line
if we're on this planet we're home yes
we're going back it's kind of like a
funny way to speak right because the
places aren't it's not going to be the
same as as well of course it's changed a
lot actually but yeah and you're not
even going back you're going forward to
somewhere and I think we'll be talking
about this a lot today it's okay to
glance in the rear view and we're going
to do a lot of that as we look back at
what we've done as the minimalists over
the last 13 years and I just want to be
clear Ryan going back or going forward
to Montana that's a very that's a good
distinction man I like that well I think
that the the key here is some things
will obviously change around the podcast
a bit he'll be calling in regularly I
just want to be clear about that Ryan is
still you know co-founder of the
minimalist we're still the minimalists
you'll still see him in fact
Ryan yeah we have this for our audience
for the days that you aren't here this
is sexy my good friend
you can go to my camera here I gotta
leave another week before I move um can
I borrow that fruit
you no I'm gonna have to clean it up
first
again if you're listening to the audio
version of the podcast which most of you
are there is a cardboard cutout of Ryan
in our studio right now so whenever he
calls into the podcast you'll get the uh
well this version of him and uh it's
actually not wearing pants so you guys
can't see that on camera but just know
Heidi whities
anyway we'll be checking back in with
cardboard Ryan 2D Ryan in a bit when you
think about the 2D version of you is
maybe the most minimalist version of
Ryan you know what 2D might be too many
dimensions
there's a Chain of Thought You Gotta
finish though because you were saying to
our audience let's be clear here's what
it does me here's what it doesn't mean
yeah so what what here's what it does
mean the podcast is still going forward
Ryan and I started talking about this
years ago he's been wanting to find his
way forward to Montana and absolutely
loves Los Angeles loves the work that we
do through the minimalist and we've been
talking about over the years we've tried
different iterations to try to make it
work but back in February we started
planning what are the next steps of what
we do and we had a few options we could
put on the table we could just dissolve
the minimalists yeah I realized recently
this is the first time we're going to be
living in different states since I think
we were 10 years old for any of
appreciable period of time yeah you
moved to Florida for you know six months
or whatever at one point and and so for
the last 32 years our friendship has
evolved 15 20 different times over that
time period yeah and it will continue to
evolve as we go forward but that also
means the podcast evolves and we put
these options on the table did we just
walk away from the podcast and the
minimalists and I'm always willing to
walk away from anything because if
you're not willing to walk away from
something you're forever tied to it and
then it becomes a burden hasn't that
been the whole point of the minimalists
is we're willing to walk away from it
anything even the minimalists and we're
gonna be talking today about endings and
how endings can become New Beginnings as
well and if you don't like the term
ending we can use terms like
recalibration
reconbobulation
reconfiguring and so today we're facing
one of those events yeah an ending and a
new beginning yeah you could call it a
graduation
um I mean like we can still call it
ending but that's kind of how I'm
looking at it yeah graduating from Los
Angeles graduating from this version of
the minimalists which by the way we've
gone through several iterations of the
minimalists when we started the the blog
it was just a Blog in 2010. yeah and
then went through the touring iteration
we've gone on 10 tours over the last 13
years
um and we've gone through the podcast
the films there's been a bunch of
different iterations of the minimalists
I'm excited to talk about what is going
to be coming next but I I thought
I'd also mention that Ryan and I will
continue to work together on some
projects but we will work separately on
some projects as well I've got some book
ideas film ideas different things that
I'd like to do Ryan's got some stuff
that we'll talk about here as well and
so I wanted to use this time Ryan to
interview Ryan Nicodemus Joshua Fields
Milburn interviews Ryan Nicodemus I I
would love to to start here I do want to
say I think I think there is
um and maybe we covered on the private
podcast but there's a very valuable
lesson I think we can tweeze out of how
we got to almost dissolving the
minimalists we're skipping it's not for
the sake of transparency as much as it
is like the sake of really sharing
something with our audience you know
yeah yeah I think we're going to get
really vulnerable today on especially on
the private version of the podcast some
things we want to talk about with
respect to our own lives and and
recognizing this point that we were
getting what what we had to recognize to
get where we are right now yeah and
while I see this as an A type of ending
I really see it as a new beginning A New
Beginning for the minimalist A New
Beginning for us our friendship but also
a new beginning for Ryan Nicodemus so I
got a few questions for you we're going
to start off with some softballs and
we'll just see where it goes from there
let's do it by the way it sounded so
funny you were like I know exactly what
you meant but you're like we're gonna
get vulnerable on the private podcast
reminds me of like those wrestling
fights as kids where it's like one
wrestler would come out and get ready to
fight the other guy and they're like
these guys are are going to fight but
only on June 25th
80 a ticket there are a few things we
don't want to talk about publicly and so
we thankfully have the the private
podcast to do that over on patreon
patreon.com the minimalists so Ryan I
know you've been looking back at Montana
for a while my first question is going
forward what are you most excited about
with respect to getting back to Montana
um there's a
there's a system of support in Montana
that I need to get a little bit more of
um at least five more years if not ten
more years also mirai's parents they've
got some greenhouses and they need some
help but just like Garden work see this
is how I know I'm old dude I'm excited
about Garden work
I'm like can't wait to get to them
Gardens like oh I'm like oh no that's
how you know you're evil yeah yeah
evolved right yeah porch didn't one of
my favorite things to do
um so so there is a system of support
that I really look forward to getting
access in Montana that comes down to
Nature it's a beautiful system of
support it comes down to having access
to a lot of that as well a lot of nature
um being there with uh just some friends
that we had to you know kind of thin the
relationship out a little bit when we
moved out here so looking forward to
um
getting them back in the fold and
supporting each other with what we need
um I got a buddy there who uh it's it's
Mariah's best friend and you know what
what what's mine is my eyes and what
Mariah's is mine so he's my best Montana
friend anyway so Kelsey um he plays
first big office so I'm like looking
forward to like playing with him and
he's got a couple other buddies it's
dude I've been not playing a ton a ton
but like um it's something that Montana
has like two frisbee golf courses within
like
I don't know 10 minute drive of our
house yeah we're in L.A it's like you
know 22 no traffic an hour with traffic
which that's I'm not complaining it's
just you know it's more convenient to
like do some of that stuff out there
um but also when it comes to
I don't know man like uh like the Arts
in Missoula it's like such a low barrier
of Entry like if I wanted to go audition
for a community play I could probably do
that and like get some of that
experience and I didn't do that enough
in Missoula
um the world outside of Hollywood the
world outside of Hollywood right that's
what they call it it's a sick name
actually
last night actually I was telling Ella
my 10 year old daughter because she was
talking about she wants to try out for a
play at some point because one of her
friends was in a play and I told her
your story of when we first moved to
Montana together you tried out for a
play you got the lead you stumbled your
way into the lead role of a play even
though you didn't have any experience in
the Performing Arts yeah and I thought
that was so fascinating I think that is
sort of the synecdoche of Missoula you
can accidentally stumble your way into
the lead role of a play and it it seems
like La would be the place you go to for
something like that but it's actually a
place like Missoula Montana where things
like that happen yeah because like
there's just a lot of
culture per capita there I mean it's the
same thing in LA
um but yeah it's just like a little gem
I actually kind of feel bad because Josh
and I have talked about it so much like
I was in Montana a few years back
walking down uh in Missoula like in the
city and two people stopped me and
they're like I'm here because of you and
Josh I was like oh no
how many people do we get to move out
here because it is like the population
is kind of booming and like housing is
kind of a an issue and
um but anyway uh yeah no I'm I can't
wait to go back there and deal with all
that too all the newness yeah you were
kind of saying it earlier like it's
definitely changed a little bit Yeah but
uh hard to hard to change those
mountains man what about La yeah you're
obviously going to miss some things
you've fallen in love with LA over the
last six years we're gonna miss yeah by
the way I love that about you that you
you don't have to hate on LA to move
away to some other place that you love
like it's so easy for people to just
kind of be uh what's the word I'm
looking for
um polemic about it or learning advice
about it like oh la stinks I but you can
say that you love just about every place
you've been so I I appreciate that but
anyway hey man you you know I always
think about
um
when you say things like that about how
uh I'm gonna butcher quote but it's you
don't have to believe you don't have to
not believe you just have to listen take
it in so
um you've helped me get there is what
I'm trying to say TK oh man yeah
um which I don't which it's really easy
to get through because La is freaking
awesome
um and so is Ojai and so is the rest of
the freaking world and I'm glad that I
get access to this place what am I gonna
miss about it
um
I will be here so much like a part-time
life in L.A I don't really plan on
missing anything that makes no sense you
know what I do plan on missing which
this is not so bad but I saw this
question I was like what can I say that
I'm gonna miss
so you're gonna have to like help me out
with this
um at Whole Foods
they have these Thai curry cashews
that are out of this freaking world dude
and I can't order them on Amazon in
Missoula and I can't uh I can't go to
the good food store and get it and I
don't want Whole Foods if you're
listening Whole Foods do not come to
Missoula
or if you do just open up a cashew store
actually if you're listening just send
me a box of Thai curry cashews anyway
um no I uh I was thinking about I'm like
oh that's one thing that I'm not gonna
have access to it's like little things
like that so there are some conveniences
that I won't have full-time access to
but
distance makes the heart grow fonder
yeah and I think that's when I say what
are you going to miss quite often for me
the things that I miss are the things
that I enjoy the most because if I
didn't enjoy it then I'm not going to
miss it if I have pain in my knee I
don't ever Miss oh I really miss having
that pain in my knee right now when it's
gone I'm like yes this is great but like
for example with my wife if I spend
every waking moment of every day with
her I don't have the opportunity to miss
her we don't have the enough distance to
create that same desire and so maybe
you'll even desire those cashews more
now that you don't have immediate access
to them yeah yeah
or the um
what are some of the hardest lessons or
maybe the hardest lesson of the last 13
years since we December 10th 2010 or
December 14th rather 2010 we started the
minimalists.com what was the what has
been one of the most difficult things
that you've learned over those 13 years
man
um
and do you have a favorite let me let me
speak to this question that you have
written here because this is because
it's kind of a different question the
question is what was the hardest thing
to do these last 13 years
and that is 100 leaving the same state
that you're in that's the it's one of
the hardest things I've ever had to do
wow talk about that
um
oh buddy like you've just supported me
so much and I'm gonna miss it man but I
know I know you'll still support me out
there and it's still possible to support
someone from a distance right yeah so
for me the relationship is getting
thinned out as an extrovert I'm like oh
Josh as an introvert is like it's it's
getting stronger
wait so I I want to kind of have a um a
clear idea of how to picture this
because I know you guys are close but
you also live in very different parts of
LA I know y'all aren't hanging out every
day every weekend kicking it you have
different types of hobbies you like to
engage in so what does it actually look
like in day to day some random
completely average Wednesday afternoon
what does his him being far away look
like for you on a regular Wednesday
afternoon well not all my Wednesdays are
the same I think I understand what
you're asking though uh it's having the
access to Melbourne and I see him more
often than you think and uh definitely
more than you and your wife buddy we're
gonna do dinner ever dude can we do
dinner before we go can you commit to
everyone on this podcast right now that
we're gonna freaking hang out before I
leave I Just Praise them being able to
love other places without hating on L.A
I take it back because he clearly can't
love Josh but I hate no me
well Josh is a good friend unlike some
other people some like other people I
know who don't know how to hang out
it's funny that I'm seeing the dichotomy
here because I don't see our
relationship changing appreciably I do
see it I literally see it strengthening
and especially the conversations we've
had over the last five or six months at
this point I see a growing stronger
weathering some discontent in our own
relationship and I think the
relationships that thrive or the
relationships that are able to handle
conflict without blowing up without
going nuclear without them saying all
right it's time for World War III but
it's being able to say hey we disagree
about these things now Ryan and I are
such appreciably different people I was
I brought my daughter to a pet store not
that long ago and they have these
chinchillas there that I guess you could
take home but you can have own you can
buy two they won't let you buy one
apparently but you have to buy two they
need someone with them all the time I
realize oh Ryan is a chinchilla yes and
it's not just all the body hair either
which is really soft
but no Ryan being the extreme extrovert
he
um is always with Mariah whenever I hang
out with Ryan it's either for the work
stuff that we do or it's with Ryan and
Mariah right he has this other
chinchilla with him right yeah and what
is fascinating about that is I know that
if I were to live his life I would be
miserable and and the opposite would be
true and this is one I why I have
problems with prescriptions because you
should live this way you should behave
like this you should do these things in
this sequence you should use these
ingredients in your own life and you can
give that to someone you can hand them
all of your ingredients and now they're
making something but they don't enjoy
the taste of it yeah and what I love
about Ryan's and my Dynamic is even
though our personalities are utterly
different
um we're able to appreciate and respect
the the fact that hey you're different
from me I don't need you to be like me
there's the longest time I did if I I'm
living the right way and I think I'd
just convince Ryan to live the right way
too which sounds like what it sounds
like a really dogmatic religion and I'm
not using
I'm not using that to be pejorative but
it sounds like an ideology if this is
right therefore you must be wrong and
our relationship has transcended that
because a we're both able to step back
from that Ryan has taught me how to step
back from needing to change other people
and because if I needed to change him
then I would just always be miserable
and I would make him miserable as I
changed him I would I would say you
taught me the same thing
um
yeah man I got bifurcating thoughts
right now we're gonna go back to TK
Singh about the Wednesdays so uh dude
like having lunch with it be a Wednesday
specific yeah so Tuesdays um Josh and I
get lunch more often than not sometimes
we don't but sometimes you do yeah I
like those little lunches yeah you know
um
I uh it's it's weird because like it's
have it's it's having the access
like it's something that
um I didn't even realize I was kind of
um
really
it's not it's not needing but it's like
the Comfort it's like having a family
member close by yeah having like one of
my best family members close by because
Josh and I I mean you have no idea like
we and same thing with Jerome I mean
we've had to be each other's family in a
lot of ways you know so um yeah like
it's I'm kind of moving farther away
from a family member I like I'm okay to
move away from the family members that I
don't like funny how that's easier right
that's way easier yeah
um and then the uh the other thing yeah
I lost it that's all right do you
remember what you were talking about
before I went back well I was going to
ask you of you talked about some of the
hardest things but this is going to be
the hardest thing what is your favorite
thing that we've done since we started
the minimalists my favorite thing
um
that we have done do you have like a a
really a favorite memory that you of
course that you hold on to of course
dude I mean as far as you and I are
concerned yeah that year-long tour was
like Priceless man yeah and like I mean
we annoyed that we had no idea what the
hell we were doing yeah and Josh is like
we're going on tour for a year and I'm
like oh are you sure he's like I'll I'll
do it yeah we got to do it man I'll do
it on my own if you want and I'm like
come on man
I'm like I'm not really worried about me
and Josh is like no like we gotta do
this and
um
that's probably
that was that was 100 the Catapult to
all of this dude yeah I mean we had we
had been the minimalist for however long
but that tour like really we're still
getting things from that yeah you know
and when I say things it's you know
obviously I'm not getting a couch or
anything from it
no but actually I'll phrase it a
different way um we are still able to
really give a lot from that tour that
we're still giving from directly related
I mean just you know our documentary
minimalism just came back out
um and it's on YouTube for free so
that's pretty awesome that thing is
still giving like that yeah you know
it's funny I uh Sean sent me a
screenshot yesterday as of this
recording it's been out for about a week
and over 2 million of you have watched
the documentary on YouTube it quickly
became our second most popular video on
our entire YouTube channel second only
to the trailer for that same movie
amazing and yeah and so a lot of people
now that it has this new life but you're
right we went around with Matt diovella
that year he was sort of in the back
seat him and his camera equipment
lighting and all this stuff and we
filmed something that has stood the test
of time and we're able to go back and
look at it now and say wow uh I do have
some amazing fond memories from that
some of my most fond memories are in
Fargo North Dakota together no how weird
is that yeah we did uh not only do we do
a tedx talk in Fargo but we spoke at
this conference three years in a row
called Misfit we even
um we took our documentary and screened
it there for the first time it was even
not even the the finished version it was
a 2015 version Standing Ovation yes it
was amazing and in Fargo North Dakota I
realized something while I hate the
weather of Fargo I like everything else
about it and it's almost as though I was
talking to Mallory about uh to Mallory
about this before the podcast but
there's something about Fargo the
weather conditions these people in a way
or weathers them in a way that brings
out the community and the niceness and
I'm wondering if something is true with
Missoula because Missoula does not have
ideal weather for someone like me who
values the sun probably a little bit
above anything else
um but there's something about the
harshness of these climates that brings
out some of the best in people
100 man I was gonna ask you I was
writing down here I wanted to ask you
about the sun thing
um because vitamin D is important yeah
so the question is can I is it possible
I wish you could possible you know on
the lines Sean call Paul said I'm just
kidding
um is it possible to get a like a UV
light yes and like chill under that in
the mornings yeah yeah in fact uh there
is one I'll try to put a link to it in
the show notes I'll find it it's one
that Paul saladino talked about because
he lived in Seattle which is very
similar to Missoula okay and when he
lived in Seattle there is a there is a a
daylight light it's not the same thing
as the sun it's a supplement essentially
right yeah you can also supplement with
vitamin D as well so taking vitamin D
and doing the UV light I'll get twice
the crappy supplements exactly
um so this question again you kind of
ask it in a different way so the
question was what was the hardest thing
to do these last 13 13 years and then
favorite thing yeah so in real relation
to me it's it's uh it's moving back to
Montana like this is like
I cannot tell you how
good I feel about it dude how will it be
different now than it was before I mean
a lot will be the same but Missoula has
changed a lot Montana has changed a lot
especially during the pandemic a lot of
people move there but how will this be
different because you're not going back
as we said you're going forward this is
the end of one thing for a brand new
beginning what's going to look different
there yeah
um I am going to tap more into nature
for sure
so that could be
I don't know man actually I'm not even
going to say what it could be but that's
that's like one of my major contexts
moving back to Missoula I got a lot of
nature when I was there but like there
is a there is a
for example like I snowboarded maybe
half a dozen times a year
I I'm gonna you know go as much as I can
yeah I don't want to put a number on it
but I would like to
because I snowboard enough to where when
I snowboard and then by that sixth time
I'm like oh yeah and I can do double
blacks and all that stuff but if I go
even more than that like now I'm
learning new things yeah so I'm really
looking forward to kind of learning new
things with snowboarding while I'm still
kind of youngish
[Music]
there's actually the rising Rockstar
Mariah's dad kicks my ass down the hill
and he's like 73 years old that's really
what it is I just want to beat him down
now he's a skier which makes it a little
bit more difficult but I can do it
I do ski by the way too no I tried once
it was kind of bad story anyway
um and then I do remember uh what I was
gonna say earlier you talked about uh
not changing people and dude the
Platinum rule is like I cannot tell you
how that has come into play in my life
ever since I've heard you talk about
that and it's funny because I'll try to
share it with other people and I start
off with and I'm like
do you know what the golden rule is
hey Mallory do you know what the golden
rule is oh yeah there's the way you'd
like to be treated okay yeah because
everybody's heard I say it before I
guess but you would be shocked over 50
percent of the people I do this with
they're like I've never heard of it what
I'm like so then I'll tell them the
golden rule true people have they want
to be treated and they're like oh like
anyway but the Platinum rule was pretty
amazing which is treat people how they
want to be treated yes yeah yeah but uh
yeah because if I treat you how I want
to be treated maybe you don't want to be
treated like me I do want to get back to
one thing you were talking about with
respect to access and having access to
things and I I think what happens uh we
tend to take things for granted when we
have unlimited access to them it can be
friends family it could be the cashews
at Whole Foods yeah whatever it is if we
have unlimited
unrestrained access to something
it's inevitable we start to take it for
granted we don't have to but when I wake
up in the morning and the sun is coming
up and then the birds are chirping and
I'm like I just take it for granted this
is the way that things are and the only
way around that is to appreciate the
things I even do have access to or to
limit my access in some way now that can
be through ascetic practices where I
deprive myself of it for a period of
time or it can be what you're doing
right now creating some distance and I
can see in many ways our relationship
improving through the Lesser immediate
physical access to one another I mean
you've still got my my phone and we're
still going to FaceTime and all these
other fun things to supplement these are
supplements right but then the times
we're together in person when you come
back to LA or somehow you convinced me
to come to Missoula Montana in fact
convincing is not consent job
in fact this is the this is the one
thing that will get me to go back to
Missoula now I don't think anything else
would have gotten me to go to Missoula
but I can see myself now finding a
delightful path back there because my
best friend's there yeah hey that's love
man yeah yeah ma'am we got a lot of it
there's a lot in this room so you're
moving are you getting rid of any
material possessions oh yeah we just it
was funny we were going through some
stuff uh just yesterday and
um yeah we have like these old dive
computers
and we sold those and
um where I forgot about the appointment
sorry Mariah I forget appointments I
forget way more appointments than she
does let me just say that yeah if this
is a competition Ryan would have a
championship belt
dude I do it to display dominance
trying to train Mariah so uh she was an
hour late the dude was meeting us at our
place
and she was over there they're easy
there but like they didn't have each
other's phone numbers I guess anyway he
was so she was there yeah she messages
him on it was like Facebook Marketplace
talking about hey are you still here
he's like yeah we're still here an hour
later he was waiting anyway so we got
rid of the dive computers um and the
dive equipment because I don't think
we're gonna be doing that anymore
especially uh leaving L.A I got rid of
my surfboard I was throwing axes and um
when you throw axes you have to have a
coach and so it's polite to tip the
coach and like just through talking with
him he's like I just move out here I
want to go surf him I gave you surf
report he's like no I was like I have to
start but this is the surfboard I can
give you but like this is your tip dude
this is tips and surfboards yeah I tip
and surfboards yeah he was so stoked
when I came back and gave it to him the
look on his face was like oh my God the
dude actually came back and gave me a
surfboard wow yeah
um you wouldn't want me to keep going
so the people surf in Missoula folks who
haven't been to Missoula there is a Surf
Wave on the Clark Fork River down there
but I assume you need a completely
different board for that it probably
would have worked but I have too many
hobbies as it is so and honestly like
the joy that he got from me getting
that's from me giving him that surfboard
yeah um to me that Joy was bigger than
my desire to serve friends wave if that
makes any sense well yes but also if you
decide you want to pick it back up then
you can get the ideal board that
actually works best for that scenario
yeah instead of trying to drag these old
possessions from the past and fit them
into the new chapter enforcing the new
version of you yeah one thing I like
about your process is it wasn't based on
prediction but it was based on decision
making in other words you didn't look at
the surfboard and say is there gonna be
a day in the future where I have to have
it and I regret giving it up but you
just made a decision like do I choose to
keep this in my life or not in light of
other priorities I have and other things
I want to do I choose to let it go and
you you kept the power in your locus of
control rather than putting it out there
in like realities you can't predict I
think that's something useful for me as
I'm simplifying some things in my life
it's choice not prediction yeah are
there any new things you need to buy for
your move
we gotta figure that out
um
so
we there's a little bit of a gap between
when we can move in and when we get
there
so we've got like uh like a week okay
two weeks three weeks movers take a
little a little while to get there
so um yeah there's we gotta make some
decisions we're getting rid of our couch
uh that we have here that I really
really like
um yeah it's for sale Malory
twice hey man talk to me about that
couch we'll work something out oh the
couch was just like I mean if there ever
was anything I did intentional in my
home with Furniture like most of my
furniture is like
people are like hey I've got this I'm
like oh yeah I need that like my
bookshelf is one of Josh's old
bookshelves my rug is one of his old
rugs
um my wooden uh entertainment thing that
I have like that's our friend Rebecca's
um Rebecca Schaefer who I was in the
play with in Missoula um yeah so but
this couch was like
it was just something that I went out of
my way to like really get something that
I liked and I don't know what spurred it
but it's just it's real simple it's like
a Dutch from the 50s like refurbished
yeah a minimalist couch and
you were able to see it when you walked
in my home for about a week until Max
started scratching the heck out of it
yeah so now it's all covered up was it
like a nap couch reading couch watch
movies count eight foot it's an eight
foot whatever you want to do couch man
you can fit so many people on this couch
wow it's like you can fit four people on
there and it's not like that weird
uncomfortable thing it's it's like I
could lay down and there's still room
for like two people to that's it so
that's that's tough to let that one go
it's not tough no it's just the thing
that I'm Letting Go why isn't it tough
yeah oh
um I love that it's not yeah you talked
you talked about it earlier dude the the
willingness to walk away from anything
Danny I'm sorry you got to get this out
of my peripheral this is really messing
with me
he's talking about the cardboard cutout
which by the way it's been downstairs in
our little writer's room and every time
I walk in there over the last few weeks
it is terrifying to me I just think
Ryan's to move it it's the best spot for
it I just think Ryan's hanging out in
there watching me I let the Architects
downstairs borrow the room for a while
and they're like hey can we use that I'm
like yeah no problem just Ryan has to
sit in on everything and they're like
what I'm like it's the cardboard cut out
of Ryan he's she's gonna be there
regardless yeah that's awesome no the
willingness to walk away from anything
it is a superpower and we say it all the
time yeah and some people listening
understand yeah and so it doesn't mean
that you this like the couch now it's
just for whatever reason does not fit
into this new chapter the moving aspect
of it or maybe it's older now and Mac
has scratched it up or whatever it is it
doesn't fit in the new chapter if it
doesn't fit into your new home as well
yeah if it doesn't fit then of course I
want to like all he's going to do I know
it I know it you're not you're not
Johnny Cochran as much as you Aspire he
blew it though you're like if it doesn't
it's like the universe put you in that
position and you did something else with
it
if it doesn't fit
ah yeah well yeah he's uh he's acquitted
yeah if it doesn't fit you must sell it
uh or donate it or whatever yeah but
what I've what I've seen here is that
willingness to let go isn't something
that just happens overnight it's it's
almost
it's not a practice in the sense that
you need to force yourself to let go
there's no forcing here but when you
stop clinging when you stop holding on
here's what happens you get good at
Letting Go your ability to let go
increases you build up this Letting Go
muscle that allows you to let go of
anything even these prized possessions
even the things that once upon a time
you're like I would never want to let go
of this dude I didn't realize it but
we've been doing the Sedona Method from
the start of this yeah practicing
releasing yeah yeah can I let this go
right yeah and would I let this go and
when and this is your win right now now
for some people listening to this they
might recognize that yes I want to let
go of something it might be a couch it
might be a relationship it might be an
old pair of jeans it might be
a new t-shirt you just bought it doesn't
fit you that well
whatever it is or something you might
want to let go of but right now is not
your win there's a little bit too much
pain associated with it so the first
thing to do is just hold on to it and
look at it and say am I willing to let
this go
would I be fine without it yeah okay
maybe I can't let it go yet but I know
that somewhere in the not too distant
future the thing that is burdening me
right now if I let it go it will cease
to be the burden and when you see that
when you recognize the things that
you're holding on to the things that
added immense value to your life joy to
your life the relationships you held on
to the career you held on to the school
you held on to for so long if I continue
to hold on it becomes a burden and if I
want to let go of that burden I just
have to let go of the thing that is that
has become a burden for me
so Ryan you uh when you're moving there
I assume you'll be buying some new
things you'll figure all that out you'll
report back to us on I'm sure well we'll
get to to do a new minimalist home tour
yeah of uh of the new space once you're
all settled in there
but pivoting over to
another question for you what have you
changed your mind about over the last 13
years since we started the minimalists
man
um
well I mean I can talk about how I've
grown
so
you know when we first started this in
Ohio
it's like I knew that we were doing
something that was going to be really
impactful for us and potentially for
other people and then we moved out to
Montana
and um it was kind of like a perfect
storm of this
you know Letting Go simplifying you know
doing the whole uh Walden Pond thing in
Phillipsburg there
but Montana really like was actually
thinking about this earlier when you
were talking about the play Montana
really helped me like become
what I was when I moved to Los Angeles
and what that is is someone who
uh isn't scared to be themselves so when
you came to me that story that we told
about how are you like in LA and I'm
like oh it's going all right but
you know people are kind of I don't
think really La likes me and
because I ask them how they're doing and
they just kind of sweep me off like
whatever what do you want dude I don't
well you don't care how I'm doing stop
bothering me yeah and Melbourne was like
well turn it down or turn it up and I'm
like oh
I think I will turn it up and it worked
but like if it wasn't for Missoula if we
moved straight to La I don't think I
would have been able to get there I
think that uh the city would have just
chewed me up and spit me out you'd see
you see me on the corner up there on
Santa Monica covering glitter
interacting traffic directing traffic
exactly
no um
so so there's been a really nice uh
blossoming for the lack of a better word
from Missoula to LA and now la
has given me
the confidence to
I don't know just to believe myself a
little bit more like I didn't even
realize that like I've been ever since
we talked about this how many months ago
did we start talking about this February
yeah so I've just been thinking about
this over the past few months knowing
that I'm leaving La and I'm trying to a
like do all the fun things I can before
I leave
um but also what does Ellie giving me
and it is it's it's funny how
I don't know you know where I got this
um but giving me the giving me more
confidence in the sense of
so Missoula taught me how to be myself
and and Los Angeles helped me be
extremely confident in being myself if
that makes sense yeah yeah
yeah go ahead I I I would like to hear
just like a minute of yeah unpacking
that Missoula helped you become yourself
La helped you be confident with who that
self is yeah what does that mean that
means that Missoula when I left Missoula
I knew who I was
um
but coming to a city like la
you know it's hard to just be who you
are especially when there's so many
different
people doing different things and being
different things and
um like fear of looking weird
ah not looking weird fear well maybe
that's I would say if you're a rejection
which that is a form of rejection
um
yeah yeah I mean and so you're saying
that does that answer your question well
you said another minute so I'm trying to
think how I can ramble from how did the
place that brought this fear out
give you the confidence to overcome it
because it gave me the challenge too it
brought the fear out and I had a choice
and had you skipped Missoula came right
out here you what you're saying is you
may have tried to conform to someone
else's idea of who you should be
as opposed to but this is what I'm
hearing from you so correct me if I'm
wrong when you went through Missoula you
found out who you were and then you were
when you moved out here you were
challenged by other people's perceptions
impressions of you yeah so I said maybe
because I was joking about La eating me
alive if we had first moved out to LA
would have been fine yeah like we're all
everyone in this room will always be
fine like I mean that's who we are
they're they're you know I used to ask
myself how many decisions away am I from
being on the streets and it would really
mess with me and I'd ask Josh that and
Josh is like dude you would never be on
the street he's like I would never be on
the street and for some reason we were
like we would help each other get off
the street like what a silly road to go
down and um that's what I mean by
everyone in this room will always be
okay in some way shape or fashion going
back to the Judgment piece of it no it's
it's not
yeah so it has nothing to do with coming
out here and not being able to handle
the Judgment it maybe would have taught
it to me in a different way you know the
past is colored with rose colored
glasses so I'm just kind of looking at
how it all unfolded and I'm really
appreciative of how it unfolded yeah
because otherwise we can have regrets or
anything like that but if I'm holding on
to I wish it would have happened
differently this is a problem that I
have a lot I wish I could have done
something differently I wish this would
come off differently I wish people would
perceive me differently that becomes a
kind of little prison that I've
fashioned myself right needing for other
people to judge me in a different way
yeah is causing the misery in me yeah I
think what I'm hearing from you and this
is helpful for me personally is I'm
hearing that it enabled you to to let go
of some of the the Judgment of others
yeah
um
I think I just want to be seen with
everyone I mean yeah you know
so
you know and when we moved to Missoula
like I didn't know I needed this it just
kind of happened but like what I
realized is I didn't even know what I
actually wanted people to see you know
um and then and that's what I mean by
Missoula like really helped me flesh
some stuff out but I was also going
through the you know the Jehovah's
Witness stuff and like really wrestling
with that and
um that's been a that's been an awesome
Journey
uh Ireland actually I got a lot out of
Ireland when it comes to that type of
stuff which we can talk about on private
podcast of if y'all want
um but you know
what La has taught me
is that
if you want to be seen then show people
and it's up to them whether or not they
want to see you it's not up to me you
know
right I think even even the needing to
be seen though I I don't really sense
that in you in fact I see the opposite
in you you you're not peacocking you're
not look at me look at me check this out
look how great I am and to me you've
never been that way it's something I've
really admired about you you don't step
out and say I need to be seen and so
when I when I hear you say I need to be
seen that's something different from
what I think of yeah for me is like I
need to be seen so I'm going to uh punch
TK on Tick Tock I need eyeballs on me I
need likes and clicks and Views and all
that stuff you mean you mean something
deeper than that you want to be you want
your Humanity to be witnessed yeah dude
that's good well as we move forward here
toward Montana I'm interested in what
you're excited about what what things
you'll be working on our work's going to
take some different directions here the
podcast is still going to remain the
podcast it'll be in your regular podcast
feed the minimalist Ryan will be calling
in and he'll be joined by his cardboard
cutout tkm Alabama our team will be here
as well all right so I got one last
question for you as we sort of segue
into this new chapter of course the
minimalist podcast will still exist you
will be calling in from Montana you're
going to be coming to Los Angeles
regularly and we'll drag you back into
the studio whenever you're you're
willing to come here uh TK Mallory the
rest of our team will be here as well
and everything is staying the same from
that respect but this is going to be a
new beginning and I see as our work
takes us in sort of different directions
and our paths continue to intersect and
bifurcate what creative projects are you
most excited about going forward
um
yeah you know it is interesting I'm just
going to add to how you teed this up so
this moving to Montana is really like
freeing us both up to do things yeah
which is really nice
and I'll tell you one of my favorite
things that we do is the hug line so I'm
just going to go around doing hug lines
can't wait going on the hug line Tour
he's gonna have on those signs have you
seen the guy who houses free hugs and if
someone actually says three dollar
premium hugs yes yes and there's a line
with the three dollars no I don't know
how much of that is manufactured Ryan
these three words came up though during
our conversations over the last few
months small group mentoring yeah yeah
can you talk a bit about that yeah
um I was gonna say that for last but
we'll talk about it right now
um I have been on a men's team in Los
Angeles that I've talked about a ton
and like it's a few months ago
I'm sitting there delivering an exercise
an exercise on immense seam is like you
know you kind of get the men thinking
about different things in their lives
perspectives and then usually have a
conversation about uh what they find
essentially
and as I'm doing that I'm like man like
this is really what I would love to be
doing more of like this is this is like
something that if I took on like it you
know it would take a lot of work which
is fine
um but then we talked about me moving
back to Montana and I'm like oh this is
just
this is God being like yeah buddy you
know what you wanted to do that you
actually could do that if you wanted to
which is really nice so going back to
what I was saying uh with the touring
stuff and the hug line so my favorite
part is when we're in front of that
audience
100 like having that face-to-face
connection because I'm a guinea pig and
I love having 300 guinea pigs around me
um or chinchilla
I'm a guinea pig tweet that
because I mentioned Chilla and love
having 300 chinchillas around me
um I get a lot from those events yeah
and it is that personal connection so
um
I have a passion for
I have a passion for supporting people
in the way that I wish I had support
when I needed it in my life yes so
sometimes it's people younger than me
sometimes people older than me and
whatever it is but if I can if I see
that I can give someone support that I'm
like oh man I wish someone would have
done this for me like I really like
having those opportunities so I don't
know what that's going to look like
specifically I do know that um yeah like
I'll have a I'll do like a monthly
mentoring thing each month just a little
monthly mentoring message I'm struggling
with the word Mentor maybe you guys can
help me with this because like coach
seems
overused and fabricated
but I was talking to Julian Smith
yesterday about this actually and he is
a he's an executive coach and I'm like I
don't know why but that doesn't bother
me because I get a coach doesn't bother
me but I'm not that's not what I'm doing
he's in a completely different realm
um life coach we can all agree that's
outright
yeah well I love something you said to
me early on when you first started
mentoring people you said most life
coaches don't have much life experience
when you see like a bunch of 23 year old
life good now some Tony Robbins was
probably a life coach at age 23 and had
a tremendous amount of experience by
then but I think your average life coach
hasn't gone through the trauma that
you've gone through I mean Talk of the
childhood trauma and then the corporate
trauma and then the relationship trauma
and business trauma in your life you've
amounted all of this wisdom not through
winning and being the best Ryan
Nicodemus ever the best Ryan Nicodemus
ever is the result of a lot of pent-up
trauma and the accumulation of almost
residual trauma over time and the
residue from that gives you the
experience not so you can tell people
what to do but you can hold up a mirror
for them I love the word Mentor
personally I'd love to hear what TK has
to say about it
yeah so I I think in terms of Love
Languages with this right what's the
best nickname for my wife the one that
resonates with her and I and everybody
else's opinion is completely irrelevant
right we live in a world where some
people they get really mad if you call
yourself a coach where you they get
really mad if you call yourself a
whatever it may be a motivational
speaker or an executive coach all that
matters really is do you want to help
people if so who do you want to help and
how do you want to help them and what's
the love language you need to speak to
them in in order to create that
connection you want and if for them the
people that are hiring you that need
your help that are blessed by your
experience they they resonate with the
term coach it works but if they think
that term is creepy and weird it's just
like talking to your wife in a way
that's creepy and weird like you abandon
the language you don't fight for your
right to use it you say hey I'm bigger
than this particular word and you find
what works and so yeah I prefer to like
stay out of Wars concerning what people
call themselves it's funny like you get
on so social media you got entrepreneurs
debating each other about who has the
right to use the word entrepreneur
people making fun of each other for the
labels they use and it's like what a
complete waste of time man who do you
want to serve and what's the love
language for speaking to the people you
want to connect with yeah I love that
man yeah
I know this isn't what you're saying but
I like the word Mentor as well what you
said though uh that made me think of how
I might approach this is if people look
at it like it's weird or whatever it is
and it's not about looking weird as much
as it is like people judging that word
because I've had people when I was doing
the mentoring on the website people
email me they're like mentors are free I
can't believe you're charging for it I'm
like
yeah that's not how I'm doing it so I'm
worried about that type of response but
um yeah like it's not about
who judges it it's what I connect with
so I mentor
is by far the best word that I can think
of obviously because I haven't given you
any other ideas how about living coach I
promise I will be alive and have a pulse
every time
I will say this I don't know what word
you should use but but just know ahead
of time yeah that no matter what term
you use and how great you feel about it
and how much it works for your people
there will be people who make comments
about it of course it's stupid and it's
the wrong term yeah so that's
inescapable yeah absolutely we faced
that for the last 13 years call yourself
the minimalist and you realize how like
it's a benign thing to call yourself I'm
gonna call myself the mentor
no so uh no what it comes down to TK is
me it's not about what other people
Define it as it's what I Define it as
and I gotta get clear on what my content
I do know what my contacts is but
whenever that like is there a better
word whenever that comes up it's like no
I mean whatever Mentor is to anyone else
like it doesn't matter what it is to
them oh yeah well you're adding the
context to it and so whether you call
yourself a coach a mentor an advisor and
maybe there's yeah there's something to
append to that as well maybe there has
something to do with being stuck or uh
something with respect to trauma you're
a trauma advisor right and all of a
sudden that can make people think what
does that mean he's invited advising me
to how to be traumatized oh no no he's
advising me on how to let go of the
trauma perhaps okay and so what images
does it conjure and what I've
accidentally realized through the
minimalists is I didn't mean to just
frustrate a bunch of people calling
ourselves the minimalists because they
have the their own conceptions about
what minimalism is right I realize that
it by it being polarizing to at least
some extent it was more attention
getting it was not my intention early on
was to be polarizing to get attention
but that name in and of itself adds this
little bit of of tension oh wait what is
that tell me more about that and even if
they show up frustrated and then you see
them the light bulbs sort of turn on
over their head after they they start to
grasp what you mean by whatever label
you're using I call it the head tilt yes
I love it it's one of my favorite things
like when I start talking about
something that people are like what are
you talking about and then there's just
a certain point where like that's the
moment the light bulb clicks when
they're like oh
like that's what this is about I live
for those head tilts
[Music]
um the other thing I'm working on uh
working on a little secret project but
more more of that to come okay you all
know what it is but but day listening
don't know what it is
time secret project coming soon it's not
top secret if other people know it's
definitely not top secrets well it
depends on their level of Clarence
damn you got me there dude that bush
knows about it right exactly it's
probably top secret oh man but uh so
folks can go to Ryan nicodemus.com they
can put their email address in there and
you will inform them of the top secret
things once they uh once they've
received clearance yes exactly it's
really easy to get clearance just put
your email
I got one bonus question for you before
we move on to another question from one
of our listeners I want to do a quick F
merry kill with you Ryan let's do it
everyone's familiar with this game right
so 20 year old Ryan 30 year old Ryan and
40 year old Ryan who do you f who do you
marry and who do you kill interesting
interesting wow by the way my favorite
novelist I'll tell you what my answer
was right away I'd marry four-year-old
Ryan he's awesome oh I'd kill 30
or 30 year old Ryan because
20 year old Ryan and 40 year old Ryan
both of them know how to have the best
sex
but 40 year old Ryan comes comes with
something different than just really
good sex comes with a matured man
so uh yeah I I I'd F 20 year old Ryan
kill a 30 year old Ryan and marry
four-year-old Ryan sorry third year old
round that's my answer as well awesome
[Music]
[Laughter]
that was good we've got a question here
from Deirdre
hello I'm Deirdre and I'm from
Lethbridge Alberta Canada and lately I
have found myself drawn more and more to
the podcast and all that you were
sharing
I Used to Know My Style but now post
pandemic and as I'm accepting that I am
approaching 50. I find I'm transitioning
into this new phase of life and yet I
don't really know my style anymore
I'm no longer drawn to my old clothes
shoes purses and such and yet I can't
seem to let them go even though I I'm
not using them
part of this is that I get myself hung
up on the amount of money I've spent on
what I have and I feel like I'm just
throwing good money away
but I also tell myself that I'm not
using it anymore and I should let it go
I realize or rather I'm proving to
myself that I don't meet these things
and yet
I just can't take that step
[Music]
I don't know maybe it's a fear of change
what used to be my style and what was
known as my thing that being my
fantastic fashionable shoes and purses
are no longer what I'm drawn to
so who am I now
I would love to hear your group's take
on transitioning through life's phases
thanks and all the best bye
I thought this was a great question
because it was a typical clothing
question to start and then it ends with
but wait who am I now as I transition to
this new stage of my life and my
identity is so tied up not in the future
it's not even tied up in my present self
it's tied up in all the clothes the
awards the achievements the jobs the
history of me becomes who I am TK I
thought maybe we could start talking to
Deirdre about the sunk cost fallacy and
then we can get a bit more esoteric
yeah I mean everyone has an expensive
past because all of us have spent all of
our life energy up until this point
investing in that pass and part of what
it means to evolve is figuring out a way
to reframe our past so that it doesn't
feel like waste to let it go and so the
sun cost fallacy is basically about
saying hey that money has already been
spent that investment of Life Energy has
already been made there's no choice I
can make to get that back or to keep
that right and so it's really about
reframing it and saying
how can I use these things that are no
longer useful to me as an act of
generosity because when you throw it
away it feels like waste and that was
that was the language that she used
right it feels like I'm throwing away
all this money that I spent but we don't
feel that way when someone says hey you
know I'm really in a position of
financial need is there anything you
could do to help me out we say oh yeah
I'll write a check for that cause we
don't feel like we're wasting hard
earned money we feel like we're being
generous and we're putting that to work
for a good cause and we can do that with
these things that we spent a lot of
money on you're not throwing it away
You're empowering someone else to enjoy
a form of abundance that has take taken
the role of excess in your life and
that's a beautiful thing that's a gift
that you can offer the world Ryan how
about you talk about how your style has
changed over the years and we could talk
about that literally it's called fashion
Millburn look it up I told myself on the
way here I'm like I'm gonna use that
line at least once during this podcast
thanks for setting me up like that
so your fashion has changed quite a bit
over the years we're gonna do a photo
tour of us over the last 42 years here
in a little bit I think I've got 15
photos that's awesome of of us sort of
looking back and you'll see quite
literally how our style has changed but
what have you learned about your own
style that has prevented you from
clinging to a bunch of clothes that you
no longer enjoy
I mean it was at a certain point I think
it was actually the
watching the documentary my first one
yeah
uh
that documentary is like yeah I just
love the documentary so much that might
be that might be uh you know for me I
know that we feel different about it but
I'm like that might be my Mount Rushmore
and that's okay like if that's my Mount
Rushmore I'm totally happy with that
that is a beautiful documentary with the
worst ending not when Josh said love
people use things but there I am
standing in that blue shirt
and I'm like damn it Nicodemus
I was like oh I'm wearing this for our
lights in La I'm gonna wear color
anyway so when I saw that I'm like oh
like I don't I don't feel good in that I
don't look great in that so
um I think that's probably when I
finally got rid of the last little bit
of those of those different uh types of
clothing so deidre's question was about
wait beating herself over wasting money
can you paraphrase her question for me I
mean ultimately her question is and I
wrote this down I would love to hear the
group's take on transitioning through
life's face ah yeah that's a great
question I think ultimately where you go
with a question like that is the clothes
that you're struggling with letting go
of it's never about the clothes no
exactly and that's what I was thinking
I'm like maybe there's some like trauma
she hasn't healed from
like that's a perfectly fine question to
ask yourself and if the answer is no
there's not any that's great but maybe
there is and if the answer is yes then
you've got to figure out how to deal
with that trauma but there's clearly
something deeper going on inside so with
my transitions that I've made from
I don't know age how old are we when we
started this 16 no I'm like age 30 to
now yeah
um it's having good friends it's having
good community
it's having a good therapist that I can
call on that I might only call him once
a year or shoot once every every other
year but like I know like when I can't
work through something and I need a
non-biased perspective to help me look
at something that I really I can usually
figure it out on my own but believe it
or not sometimes I just need someone
else but uh yeah uh that's a great tool
to have in your back pocket so Deidra
start with
the people you're surrounding yourself
with what's your community look like and
if there is something that you might
need to dig in a little bit deeper get
someone to help you dig in deeper yeah
yeah
if I were to look at it if I were in her
shoes the thing that I would want to
understand is that your future self does
not care about the clothes from your
past that's yeah and so the more that I
cling to whatever is going on in the
past the furniture from my past the
relationships from my past the career
from my past the trophies Awards
material possessions from my past the
more I cling to those the more I'm
burdening my current self and thus
burdening My Future Self as well yeah so
the question is like what are what can
you gain by letting this go Diego
like what are you gonna gain five years
from now one year from now two years
from now yeah like that's that
definitely is some good leverage to have
yeah because if you aren't willing to
let go of it you won't gain any of the
things you're talking about gaining and
that's really the only wrong answer is
just doing nothing yeah I hate to
moralize it but if there was if there
was a
poorest answer maybe that's that's just
you know maybe that's a better way to
look at it yeah that's the yeah the
irony of this is you're not actually
doing nothing clinging is an act in and
of itself and so when I feel like oh I'm
just gonna throw my hands up and do
nothing well no you're not doing nothing
you're still holding on to something
that is weighing you down yeah one of my
favorite podcasts probably my favorite
podcast episode ever I shared this with
you a few months ago Ryan it's from a
friend of ours Rob Bell
he had this uh podcast episode called a
pair of docses because he has these two
paradoxes a pair of dogs Professor Sean
put a link to this in the show notes
please I will paraphrase these to
paradoxes I'll paraphrase this pair of
docses the first one is the more love
you're living in the clearer your
boundaries will be
for the longest time I thought that if I
established a boundary with someone
maybe that was being unloving or unkind
saying no to them wasn't nearly as
loving as just saying yes yes yes yes
yes but if you have no boundaries in
your life you have no love the bigger
thing that I think applies here to
deirdre's question is the second paradox
the more grounded you are in your sense
of self
the more yourself
becomes flexible the more flexible you
become if you know who you are as a
person
because let's face it if I don't know
who I am I'm going to stick to what an
ideology a thought pattern a belief
system that was simply handed to me this
must be who I am it's not to say there's
no value in those things there can be
value in those things but if I don't
know who I am I'm going to be really
rigid especially about the things that
don't matter
and it's okay to be rigid even but you
can be rigid and be flexible to be
flexible just means that I can bend
without breaking and that's where
Deirdre is right now with respect to her
clothes if I get rid of these who am I
as a person oh the fact that you're
asking that question means you're
becoming more flexible you're realizing
that the clothes from the past don't
make you who you are today and anything
you're holding on to actually gets in
the way of that flexibility and if it
gets in the way of your flexibility you
are actually getting in the way of your
self
yeah if I get rid of this stuff that's
weighing me down
who will I become
you will become the lightness that you
feel
when you are finally free to live the
life you want to live letting go is
about giving yourself that power that
freedom that flexibility to go to all
the places you want to go and it's also
not just about you it's about giving
other people the abundance the resources
that they need in order to grow
you're at this place Deirdre
we call it a necessary ending and when
you think about that term ending it has
a lot of connotations quite often when a
relationship ends there's some huge blow
up and there's a fight and oh my God I
can't believe you did this I'm gonna
start blaming you accusing you of these
things that made me upset right that's
not what an ending in is and there's
this book uh the three of us were at a
Dave Ramsey event a few months ago and I
ran into Dr Henry cloud and he wrote the
book I walked up to him Dave introduced
me to him he goes you guys got to meet
each other like minimalism and the whole
boundaries thing I said oh my gosh
you're Henry Cloud I quoted from your
first book in my last book uh a lot of
people use things I talked about
boundaries in there quoting from him he
goes have you read my book necessary
endings I said no I've never even heard
it he goes it's about minimalism
I said oh wow all these different names
for minimalism and what he really talks
about I'm gonna read a few things from
the book real quick because I think
they're applicable to this episode
at large but I also think they're
applicable to deirdre's question here
the first line of the book you know I'm
a sucker for first lines Ryan thanks for
showing me that first line battle by the
way ah it's my favorite thing to do I
have passed that on to other people just
go to a bookstore if you hate bookstores
even you just go to a bookstore you each
pick out a random book off the shelf the
cheesier the better and sometimes even
the cheesiest books have awesome first
lines and some of my favorite books of
all time have pretty mediocre first
lines but this first line it's a great
book but this is a great first line
today may be the enemy of your tomorrow
my goodness the next sentence actually
I'm going to read the next section
because I think it encompasses that the
next sentence even better so there's a
section early on in the first chapter
it's called the universal universality
of endings
why endings
whether we like it or not endings are a
part of life they are woven into the
fabric of life itself both when it goes
well and also when it doesn't on the
good side of life for us to ever get to
a new level a new tomorrow or the next
step something has to end
life has Seasons stages phases
for there to be anything new old things
always have to end
and we have to let go of them infancy
gives rise to toddlerhood and must
forever be shunned in order to get the
Independence that allows a child to
thrive
later childhood itself must be given up
for people to become the adults that
they were designed to be getting to the
next level always requires ending
something leaving it behind and moving
on growth itself demands that we move on
without the ability to end things people
stay stuck never becoming who they are
meant to be never accomplishing all that
their talents and abilities should
afford them in business endings often
are absolute Necessities for a
turnaround or for growth to occur
endings are also important in our
personal lives
there are relationships that should go
away practices and phases that must be
relinquished and life stages that should
come to an end to open up the space for
the next one
a breakup an ending of some friendships
or activities or an unplugging from some
new commitments or from some commitments
often signals the beginning
of a whole new life
yeah
I think that
that word endings is scary
because we think of divorce and I love
the word you used earlier with
graduation because that's an ending
you're ending High School right but also
there are other words I find in my own
life that are more empowering words like
recalibrating or I remember we ended our
2017 tour Ryan we happen to be in the
airport in Milwaukee
and they you know when you go through
the airport and go through all the
machines you feel discombobulated right
they have a Zone an area that is called
the reconbobulation area oh yeah is that
right they call it that and it's not
even a real word but someone who is
designing this said hey I recognize how
discombobulated you feel after going
through everything that you've just gone
through and what a beautiful metaphor
yeah everything you've just gone through
now is time for a reconbobulation we
need to reconbobulate our lives because
whatever was just out there we just
ended that we're in the airport now and
we're recombobulating yeah and I feel
like that's what we're doing here with
the minimalists it's not an ending so
much as it is a graduation or a
reconbobulation I want to highlight
something uh using what TK said earlier
about knowing
what you're going to become
because that
is sometimes the hardest part and that
is why sometimes people cling because
they're scared of the unknown
so like you can either embrace the
unknown I love embracing the unknown I
thrive in the unknown
um
I am starting to learn how to thrive in
the planning stages which
um I can't wait to have lunch with you
after this man to kind of talk about
some of the stuff anyway
um but yeah I I just don't want to
undermine how important everything that
you just read There is
but if you don't know what you're going
to become sometimes that might be what
you have to figure out first and here's
the thing that I thought of when you
were talking TK Los Angeles people want
to come out here because they see the
lights and they see Hollywood and
whatever they see they're like oh la
if you come out to LA
and you don't know what you want
it's going to be a very rough road
like it's not a matter of
um
it chewing you up and spitting you out
although a better chance of that
happening if you don't know what you
want but La it has everything you want
and if you don't know what you want like
you're going to be pulled in 17
different directions so
um I think what you just read is amazing
but I think what TK was saying is like
pairing it with that is really important
yeah there's I'm thinking of like a
little aphorism here like if you don't
know what you want paradoxically you're
guaranteed to get it but also you will
never get it right yeah if you don't
know what you want you're not going to
get what you want and sometimes
something has to end in order for you to
get what you want there's not necessary
ending the last section I want to read
from this that I think ties this up
nicely it's the end of the I think first
chapter or second chapter he says
endings are not only a part of life
they are a requirement for living and
thriving professionally and personally
being alive requires that we sometimes
kill off things in which we were once
invested uproot what we previously
nurtured and tear down what we've built
for an earlier time
refraining giving up
throwing away tearing down hating what
what hating what we once cherished are
all necessary endings endings are the
reason you are not married to your prom
date nor still working in your first job
but without the ability to do endings
well we flounder we stay stuck and we
fail to reach our goals and dreams or
Worse we remain in painful and sometimes
destructive situations endings are
crucial but we rarely like them hence
the problem this is why we avoid endings
and he goes into this list of
reasons that we might avoid ending so
let's talk about these individually here
we hang on too long when we should in
something now
I think that one is first for a reason
quite often we know we'd be better off
ending something but I'll wait till next
Tuesday or I'll wait till next month
I'll wait till next quarter I'll wait
till next year
well why do I wait for those things
right and he talks about the fear of
Confrontation we're afraid of hurting
someone you can't have a conversation if
you can never hurt someone because it's
not up to you whether or not I'm going
to hurt TK now I can present it in a way
that isn't badgering him if Ryan and I
need to have a difficult conversation I
can have love and compassion but if he's
hurt by that I don't get to decide
whether or not he's hurt by that and so
we avoid an ending because we avoid the
conversations altogether
he also says we do not know if an ending
is actually necessary or if the person
is fixable
so we avoid an ending why
because I can fix that person or I can
fix that situation hmm
you know um I think it's easy to confuse
knowing what we want with possessing the
intellectual ability to conceptualize
and articulate in a way that makes it
sound sensible to other people we live
in this culture of justification you
don't get to be you and do what you want
to do unless you can explain yourself to
me and defend it against all of the
objections and concerns I might raise
but knowing what you want is often a
very intuitive visceral thing you can
feel it you may not know how you're
going to get there you may not know how
to explain it to someone else right now
but it's just like when you put your
hands under the the faucet and you begin
to wash your hands you know if that
feels too hot you know if that feels too
cold and if it's comfortable and I come
along and I say no that's too hot you
can know if I'm right or wrong just by
how it feels even if you can't beat me
in an argument and sometimes we have a
whole bunch of options that are all good
and innocent and nice and profitable but
the one that's right for you you gotta
connect with it at the level of feeling
and intuition and put explaining
yourself to others in the background
make that secondary that comes with time
but you got to zoom in on what's right
for me what feels right for me there's
something there about if I can't explain
this to everyone then I won't end it as
well right even though something should
end and that's where Deirdre is right
now like I feel like I need to be able
to rationalize to other people or even
to myself I need to be able to
rationalize it and explain perfectly why
I let those things go well the only
answer there is because it didn't feel
right anymore and it was time to move on
yeah
so we talked about I'm afraid of
confrontation I'm afraid of hurting
someone we are afraid of Letting Go and
the sadness associated with ending we do
not possess the skills to execute the
ending we do not even know the right
words to use
we have had too many and two painful
endings in our personal history so we
avoid another one when we are forced
when endings are forced upon us we do
not know how to process them and we sink
or flounder
and ultimately we do not learn from them
so we repeat the same mistakes over and
over
I've seen that in my own life
that something that should have ended a
long time ago I pathologized ending as
being a bad thing and right now we're
facing an ending but we're actually just
facing a new beginning and so if I just
rephrase that story a little bit I'm not
even thinking of graduation is a new
beginning yes it's celebrating that's
what I wanted to do today is I want to
honor Ryan Nicodemus I want to celebrate
Ryan Nicodemus and you're still going to
hear from Ryan Nicodemus but I wanted to
celebrate this new beginning this
graduation of sorts because
yes it's great to look in the rear view
and we'll we'll have some fun with that
but what's much more exciting is what's
about to happen not what has already
happened yeah
it feels to me like an evolution which
isn't good or bad yeah it's survival I
mean that it's you know at its core
um
but in this way there is it there is a
sense of survival that um
this uh the reason why this ending is
happening
um but
yeah it's it's about
it's about taking this opportunity
to really choose like what do we want to
evolve to and anytime something ends I
mean maybe that'll help with because you
keep saying ending and I'm like man it
sounds so harsh I don't feel like it's
an ending but it's because I'm assigning
things like graduation to it I'm
assigning things like Evolution to it
yeah and I guess maybe that's what I'm
really trying to say here anyone who is
hearing ending and it's like hitting
them it's stinging them because it's
stinging me it's really weird
um it's not about
the the bad context that you have with
it like you can choose your context that
you want to have with whatever ending is
happening in your life yeah and the the
word that I often use in my own life is
not an ending but it's an untethering of
sorts right tethers aren't bad you know
if you're bungee jumping you better hope
that tether's going to work right but at
some point if I walk around forever with
that bungee jumping tether I'm
constricted in a way that I do not want
to be constricted or restricted from
going where I want to go really useful
in some instances but if I'm not willing
to untether I'm never going to get away
from that particular activity right and
so when I recontextualize it yes
graduation yes recombobulation yes
recalibration you know when you're
riding the bike you're always
recalibrated especially me I'm also off
balance I have to constantly recalibrate
but that's how balance works it's
through constant recalibration there's
an ending a beginning ending beginning
ending Beginnings that's all it is it's
a cycle but it's also an untethering and
that's what I look at here not being
Tethered to the way that things were
that's how we move forward
and that's really the core of what
minimalism is right it's not about
renouncing things it's not about
uncoupling from them it's about being
unburdened by them it's about
Reinventing the relationship between you
and the world around you so that you
experience that world of stuff as
something that amplifies your quality of
life enhances it and whenever it gets in
the way you say well let me rearrange it
or establish a relationship to it so
that it ceases to be clutter and that's
what you're doing with your
transitioning your untethering or
whatever we want to call it you're going
to you're saying I still love this place
I'm not renouncing LA but I'm changing
my relationship to it so that it
continues to be a space that brings me
joy I love that yeah
I love the word that you just used
amplify because if we're getting back to
deirdre's question here
clothes or fashion is great as an
amplifier if it amplifies your
personality if it shows who you are as a
person if it amplifies your Humane your
humanness right it can be wonderful
fashion is terrible as a crutch I have
to do this I have to dress this way I
have to show myself like this oh then it
feels so restrictive I don't want that
but if I get to because it's an
amplifier man that's awesome yeah
I love it well coming up I know uh TK's
got some interview questions for Ryan
we're going to tackle on the private
podcast also 13 years of minimalist
experiences A Memory Lane Photo tour but
first real quick for right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists we're really
excited about this we do a patreon live
stream every week for our private
podcast subscribers anyone who
subscribes to the video version of the
private podcast we're moving those to
Friday's completely uncoupling them from
the podcast itself and return it to a
zoom call we're calling them Friday
afternoon minimalist zooms fams uh is
our is our acronym and we're going to
hop on Zoom with you now this enables us
to sort of be in a live event with you
even from several thousand miles away
it's noon Pacific so that's 3 P.M
Central every Friday or most Fridays the
way we'll handle it and you'll get an
email beforehand every Friday with a
private link so you can join us on the
zoom and we're going to see you face to
face now if you're super introvert and
you're like you can just turn your
camera off turn your mic off you can
interact with us as well you can we'll
turn your mic on if you want to interact
with us and and you can come in to the
room ask a question we can have a
conversation or the three of us from our
separate homes can all just pontificate
wildly until someone steps in and has a
question or observation that they want
us to talk about what are you guys
excited about with respect to these fams
any face-to-face interaction I get with
our audience is awesome more chinchillas
yeah and it's funny I don't know why we
haven't been doing this before I know
because all the Chinchillas have been
watching me
[Laughter]
but it's really me who wants to see the
chinchillas anyway that's right and
seeing the sort of face-to-face
interaction with them it adds this other
level this other layer this intimacy of
oh I get to see you and talk to you
similar to our Live Events it's not just
like a live event but it's much more
similar it's us in a room together
uncoupled from the podcast and we're
right there talking to you face to face
if you want to interact with us great or
you can be the fly on the wall and you
can just watch these Friday afternoon
minimalist zooms as well yeah man I just
love that we're breaking the fourth wall
I think the thing that's great about the
internet is like we get to connect with
people in different ways but one of the
things that's still kind of missing is
that the the relationship between time
and content it's it's really odd because
you have to put something out there
first and then people can tell you how
they feel about it and then you decide
if you want to interact with them over
that or not right but to have real-time
interaction where people can talk with
you while you're in the middle of the
creative process where that can itself
be the creative process that to me is
exciting it it's it mimics some of the
elements we love so much about the live
event Ryan and I have talked about that
a lot to me I think that's when this
stuff becomes the most fun when we can
involve people and we can engage each
other in real time and we'll be
involving those people we'll take some
questions from the live streams and
bring them on to the podcast as well so
you'll see in a beautiful intersection
there between those live streams in fact
what I love about this it gives us the
room to sort of make errors and mistakes
in real time and see what resonates in
real time because what you're talking
about is a lag time if you create
something a week today and you don't put
it out for a month you don't get any
feedback on it for a month if you write
a book sometimes it's like you don't get
any feedback for several years and
that's fine during the creative process
what you're talking about is Real Time
feedback real-time interaction real time
commenting and we're talking about
face-to-face interactions you see
something there through someone's
physiology that doesn't make its way
into the comment section on YouTube or
or on patreon so will these recorded and
patrons can watch them or is it just
live only great question yes it'll be
recorded and posted for one week and so
like I do with all of Ryan's of my
conversations they'll all be recorded
are you doing that too man we are
doubling the efforts
that's good I'm not doing anything
illegal because it's a two-party state
right
I love partying
so yes uh it'll be available for one
week we really love the ephemeral nature
of this and we even scheduled it in a
way that even if you live in Australia
you have to get up a little early I
think it's seven or eight a.m but you'll
be able to join us as well we have a lot
of people who listen to this podcast
from Australia and New Zealand and
throughout the world so if you can join
us live great if not you can still watch
everything that went down over the
course of the next week and then poof
it's gone we love the ephemeral nature
of these and we'll do another one next
week you can always join us for that
speaking of live stream questions we
save one from the last live stream
Alabama will you read Donna's question
for us this is from Donna on patreon the
power of a hug in 2014 I was staying at
the Hampton Inn in Oregon City Oregon
caring for my mother who was dying I was
flying in from Florida for long weekends
returning to work as best I could and
trying to keep everything in balance
jfm I ran into you in the hallway of
that Hampton Inn I recognized you in
passing and said I have read everything
you have written
thank you so much you responded politely
paused and said would hug be okay
I had not said anything about why I was
there
I just want you to know that that hug
sustained me through the last three days
of my mother's life
I will be forever grateful
now I hear Mallory tearing up but I
don't know if she's just voice acting
right now no I feel it okay yeah I do
too I first time I read this I was like
wow and and this is exactly what Ryan
was talking about with the 2014 tour
running into to someone at a uh Hampton
Inn I thought we only stayed in the Four
Seasons Ryan
I want to know when you were in Oregon
City that's Clackamas oh Clackamas
[Laughter]
you know what you know what's beautiful
about that story man
is that if it was only that person I
didn't even meet her if it was only that
person it would have made it would make
all of this worth it man and the fact
that um
there's a few others makes it just you
know sprinkles on top of everything yeah
yeah and there's something I love I I
titled this power of a hug because you
never realize like I don't remember this
specific interaction because this
happens to me so frequently but I want
to pause and make the moment special not
just for them it's special for me as
well Oz give someone a hug hear them
witness them
because we want to be seen we want to be
witnessed yeah and I don't know that I
have a duty to do that but I feel it I
feel compelled to do that because yes I
get something from someone else gets
something from it as well but talk about
one of the best ways to be present you
can tell when someone is present when
they give you a hug or often a hug bring
someone into the moment we have some
great guests on this podcast but the one
who uh stands out in terms of hugs is Dr
Zach Bush his hugs bring me into the
moment ground me in a way that makes me
realize hey it's all going to be okay we
are right here right now that's why
that's the name of that segment right
here right now it's not over there and
then some other time it's right here
right now and that's what a hug does it
brings us in to the moment right here
right now we got a bunch more to talk
about but first from Alabama what do you
got for us here's the minimalist Insight
from one of our listeners years
hi this is April from Cleveland Ohio and
I was calling to tell you guys about a
service that I find very useful in
episode 394 called simplify everything
you guys talked about clothing Recycling
and there's a service in parts of Ohio
Michigan Texas Illinois Massachusetts
Connecticut and Minnesota all you do is
go to their website at
simplerecycling.com and schedule a
pickup of your clothing and then you put
a box or bag
um on your porch and you put a simple
recycling label on it and they even have
labels on their website that you can
print up what they do is they grade all
the items collected based on quality top
quality go to thrift stores mid-graded
exported internationally and items
considered unusable or processed for raw
materials I love it because of three
reasons number one I tend to use items
until they're either ripped or stained
Beyond donating to a thrift store and I
don't want those to end up in a landfill
number two I don't have to take it
anywhere they pick up from me and number
three it's completely free to use so if
you're in one of those areas go check
them out at simplerecycling.com
all right y'all we'll see you on patreon
for the full and this is not a joke for
our conversation that we just had and we
went pretty deep I mean deeper than I
think we've ever gone and uh if you
thought that Zach Bush episode was
amazing you're gonna love this this
should be the title if you like Dr Zach
Bush you'll love this episode aliens
ain't got nothing on this podcast
oh wow so patreon.com the minimalist
free for a week if you want to join and
and check it out we just had a four hour
conversation TK he interviewed Ryan went
deep on some conversations there but
Ryan and I really broke out some of the
conversations that we've had over the
course of the last six months that
allowed us to get to this point
conversations about about resentment and
and grief and and guilt and letting go
and moving on the distinction between
ending something and evolving towards
something else
I can't wait to see where uh where we go
from here me too man I'm really grateful
uh you decided to do this uh this
episode even though it's completely
contrary to how I typically would do an
episode I've learned to be Wiggly
especially for episode 400. this is my
favorite episode we have ever done and I
gotta tell you anyone listening to this
you're dealing with resentment if you're
dealing with anger if you're holding on
to something that you really know you
should probably let go of
um you are 100 gonna get some
ingredients on how to let those feelings
go hmm yeah
well Ryan I love you brother I love you
more
I love you both we love you too buddy
all right y'all love people
and use things
thanks for listening we'll see you next
time much love
every little thing you think that you
need
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed or I bet that you'll
be fine without it foreign
foreign
every little